Western intelligence shows
that Russia is
starting to gather aircraft
near its border with Ukraine.
This is an apparent attempt to bolster
the trouble
that it's having with the land defensive.
Now they're trying to bolster it
with jets, with helicopters.
All of this
according to a new report
in the Financial Times.
All of this is also happening
is the defense secretary, Lloyd Austin,
says Ukraine is expected to conduct
an offensive against Russia
in the coming months.
And so
we believe that there will be
a window of opportunity
for them to exercise
initiative and then change.
We'll continue to to
create the right conditions
on the battlefield there.
Big questions about those conditions.
CNN's Fred Pleitgen is at the Division
Belorussian Border Crossing. Fred.
As you're hearing these warnings
from the U.S., from other Western allies,
what more are you seeing
on the actual ground?
There, Kaitlin?
I can tell you
it certainly seems as though
the Ukrainians are extremely concerned
that there might be another invasion
coming also from a territory of Belarus,
obviously involving Russian troops.
I want to show you what's going on here,
because we are in a
really remarkable place.
We're actually right on the border
between Belarus and Ukraine.
You can see here,
this is some barbed wire fence.
This was put up by the Russians,
but only a couple of yards down the road
over there.
That is already Ukrainian territory.
And as you guys can see,
it's heavily fortified.
There's several layers of barbed wire.
There's also some things
that were put up,
earth mounds to essentially stop
anyone from going through there.
That border
crossing on the Ukrainian side
is absolute utterly
barricaded from what we can see.
Now, we know that from the
Belarussian side,
this border crossing
is actually still functioning.
From the Ukrainian side, it isn't.
All the border crossings to Belarus
have been closed
because the Ukrainians
have that fear
that they could be attacked
from the territory of Belarus.
One of the things
that's also going on here
that I just want to point out,
Caitlin, is that there is actually
some international trolling
also going on here.
If our camera operator,
our photojournalist
Claudia, can try and zoom in on that,
you'll see there's
a Ukrainian flag there.
But the other flag next to
that is actually the opposition
flag of the Belarussian opposition.
And I can tell you one thing,
the Belarussian authorities
are not happy about that.
In fact,
the border guys
that were around here with
they have called that a provocation
by the Ukrainians now.
We do have to point out
we're on an organized
press tour by the Russian government.
So we're a bit restricted
in our movement. Here in the country.
And we're on the north
western border crossing
or one of the northwestern
border crossings.
And you
probably find more Russian forces,
for instance,
in the northeast
but nevertheless,
you can absolutely see the tension here
between Belarus in Ukraine,
as Ukrainians obviously
bracing for a possible
another offensive by the Russians
and fearing
that there could be elements
launched from this country
here as well, Kaitlan.
Yeah, and given the role Belarus
played in the initial invasion
almost a year ago,
you can see why the Ukrainians feel
that way.
Fred Pleitgen, fascinating report.
Thank you.